A LOT OF BARBECUES, BECAUSE SO
MANY SACRIFICE FOR US SO THAT WE
CAN DO THAT STUFF.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," WE WILL
BREAK A LOT OF NEWS TONIGHT.
WE HAVE THE CLASSIFICATION ISSUE
WE HAVE NOT ADDRESSED YET, WE
TELL YOU EVERY NIGHT ON THE
PROGRAM THAT WE ARE SO BLESSED
THAT WE LIVE IN THE GREATEST
SINGLE BEST COUNTRY THAT GOD
EVER GAVE MAN.
NEVER IN THE HISTORY OF MANKIND,
BARRY FARBER HAS SAID HAS A
COUNTRY ACQUIRED MORE POWER AND
ABUSED IT LESS THEN OUR COUNTRY,
THE UNITED STATES.
AND ALSO NEVER HAS A COUNTRY
USED ITS AWESOME POWERS AND
RESOURCES FOR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THE HUMAN CONDITION, NOT ONLY
OUR CITIZENS, BUT AROUND THE
GLOBE.
WE WILL BE THE FIRST TO SAY THAT
WE ARE NOT PERFECT HUMAN BEINGS
ARE NOT PERFECT.
BUT WHAT MAKES THE COUNTRY SO
SPECIAL, SO GREAT, SO UNIQUE IS
THAT IT STARTS WITH THE FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS.
THE DECLARATION.
TO THE CONSTITUTION, THE
BILL OF RIGHTS.
THE EXPLICIT UNDERSTANDING THAT
HUMAN RIGHTS, THEY ARE NOT
GOVERNMENT GIVEN, BUT ENDOWED BY
OUR CREATOR, AND INALIENABLE
RIGHTS FOR EVERY AMERICAN, LIFE,
LIBERTY, PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
RONALD REAGAN REMINDED US AND
POINTED OUT MANY DECADES AGO
THAT FREEDOM IS NEVER MORE THAN
ONE GENERATION AWAY FROM
EXTINCTION.
NOW, FROM WORLD WAR II WHERE MY
FATHER SERVED FOUR YEARS IN THE
PACIFIC TO THE RISE OF
COMMUNISM, TO THE FIGHT AGAINST
RADICAL ISLAMIC TERRORISM RIGHT
HERE ON AMERICAN SOIL AND
ABROAD, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE
ARE A GOOD PEOPLE.
WE HAVE ALWAYS FOUGHT TO PROTECT
THESE FREEDOMS AGAINST THOSE
THAT WOULD DESTROY OUR WAY OF
LIFE.
AND MANY IN AND OUT OF UNIFORM
HAVE FOUGHT BRAVELY GIVEN THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE DEFENDING
AGAINST THESE THREATS
ABROAD, IT IS SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT IN THIS TIPPING
POINT OF HISTORY THAT WE HOLD
OUR GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT WE PREVENT THE EROSION OF
THESE HARD-FOUGHT, ALL THE
BLOOD, AND BROIL, AND SACRIFICE
AND EXPENSE FOR OUR FREEDOMS
WITHIN THIS COUNTRY, IF WE DON'T
GET THIS RIGHT, AND PROTECT
THESE PRINCIPLES, AMERICA AS WE
KNOW IT WILL CEASE TO EXIST.
AND THAT IS WHY, FRANKLY, WE
HAVE BEEN SPENDING SO MUCH TIME
AND SOUNDING THE ALARM ABOUT THE
CORRUPT, HIGH-RANKING, NOT TO
RANK AND FILE, BROKE HER OUT IN
THE DEEP STATE, IN THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, AND THE FBI
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
ELSEWHERE, THOSE THAT SUBVERT
THE WILL OF WE, THE PEOPLE,
USING THE AWESOME POWERS THAT WE
GIVE THEM TO PROTECT US TOO
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OH,
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHC
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHE
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHR
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHH
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHL
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHA
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHY
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHC
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHI
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHT
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHN
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHO
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHF
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHP
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHA
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHI
LITERALLY IN SOME INSTANCES, OHG
CRIMES TO IMPACT THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND TRY TO IMPACT THE ELECTION
USING RUSSIAN LIES.
AND THEN AT THE END OF IT, USING
RUSSIAN PAID FOR LIES BY HILLARY
TO TAKE DOWN A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP.
A PACK OF LIES.
NOW ALL ROADS ARE LEADING TO THE
DOSSIER.
YOU KNOW THE NAMES, COMEY,
STRZOK, PAGE, BRENNAN, THEY HAVE
HATED DONALD TRUMP AND MANY
OTHERS.
THEY HAVE LATCHED ONTO HILARY'S
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
AND THEY HAVE USED THE PHONY
DOCUMENTS IN A VARIETY OF
NEFARIOUS WAYS.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SUGGESTING, OH, AND MIGHT HAVE
BEEN RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION THE
WHOLE TIME THAT SHE PAID FOR.
AND COMEY OBTAINED A FISA WARNS,
WARNS HER NUMBER 1,
OCTOBER 2016, CLAIMING AT THE
TOP OF THE FISA APPLICATION
VERIFIED AND TRUE.
HE CLAIMED THAT IT WAS TRUE AND
ACCURATE.
BRENNAN, CLAPPER WERE
PROLIFERATING THE DOSSIER LIES
THROUGHOUT THE GOVERNMENT.
LEAKS TO THE MEDIA, LEAKS TO
HARRY REID, STRZOK AND PAGE
PLANNING TO USE THE DOSSIER AS
AN INSURANCE POLICY JUST IN CASE
THE LOW SOME DONALD TRUMP WHO
SHOULD LOSE 100000000-0 WOULD
EVER BECOME PRESIDENT.
OVER THE WEEKEND, A VERY SERIOUS
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY REALLY
SAID SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
TREASON ON THEIR PART.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID.
>> STRZOK AND PAGE WHO WERE IN
CHARGE OF WATCHING THE
INVESTIGATION AND THEY WERE
SAYING THINGS LIKE, WE MUST STOP
THIS PRESIDENT.
WE NEED AN INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT, THAT IN
MY VIEW, WHEN YOU HAVE THE
PEOPLE IN THE HIGHEST ECHELON OF
THE NATION SAYING THINGS LIKE
THAT, THAT SOUNDS AN AWFUL LIGHT
LIKE A COUP, AND IT COULD BE
TREASON.
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO KNOW
MORE.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT JIM COMEY'S
ROLE WAS IN ALL OF THIS.
ANDY McCABE REPORTED TO HIM.
WHAT WAS COMEY'S ROLE IN THAT?
>> Sean: IT IS NOW INEVITABLE,
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF "IF" IT IS
"WHEN."
WE WILL KNOW ABOUT THE EXTREME,
THE POWER OF ABUSE, THE
HIGH-RANKING BUREAUCRATS, WHAT
THEY DID TO MALIGN CANDIDATES,
THEN PRESIDENT-ELECT, THEN
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP PRETTY
LATE LAST WEEK, THE PRESIDENT
GRANTED ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR
THE POWER TO JUST CLASSIFY
MATERIAL RELATED TO THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS O
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS F
THE RUSSIA WITCH HUNT.
FOUR SEPARATE OCCASIONS, THE FBI
NINE MONTHS INVESTIGATION, THE
HOUSE UNTIL COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION, THE BIPARTISAN
SENATE COMMITTEE, AND NOW THE
MUELLER REPORT.
NO COLLUSION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU WILL
SEE THE TRUTH WITH THEIR OWN
EYES, AND IT IS NOT LOOKING GOOD
TO THE FEW AT THE TOP THAT HAVE
ABUSED THEIR POWER.
IT IS NOT "IF" IT IS "WHEN."
WE WILL SEE IT.
AND THE QUESTION WILL BE WHO
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT.
TO THE SWAMP IS IN FULL PANIC
MODE.
THE MOST HOLY OVER THEN THOU JIM
COMEY KNOWS BETTER THAN ANYBODY,
ISSUING ANOTHER OP-ED, CALLING
DONALD TRUMP A DUMB LIAR AND ANY
TALK OF GOVERNMENT CORRUPTION IS
"WORST DEEP STATE CONSPIRACY EVE
"WORST DEEP STATE CONSPIRACY EV.
"WORST DEEP STATE CONSPIRACY EV"
FOR SOME REASON SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY FORGOT TO MENTION
THEIR DIRTY HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIE
DOSSIER EVEN THOUGH IT WAS HIM.
HE WAS A GUIDING LIGHT FOR
NEARLY A YEAR, AND THE VERY
BASIS FOR THE CORRUPTION
ACCUSATION.
AND NOW, REMEMBER, HE FACES THE
FACT THAT HE SWORE TO FIGHT AS
FISA COURT JUDGES THAT IT WAS A
VERIFIED BULK OF INFORMATION WAS
TRUE.
THE RAMP IT'S A FISA OF BUSE,
THAT IS NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
AND I WARNED YOU BEFORE, YOU DO
HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
YOU SHOULD HAVE TAKEN MY ADVICE
FROM THE GET-GO.
SADLY, I THINK THAT YOUR RAGE
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND INTENSE
LOVE OF THE SPOTLIGHT IS REALLY
OVERCOMING EVERY BIT OF COMMON
SENSE THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
COMEY DESPERATELY NOW TRYING TO
SHAPE THE NARRATIVE, SO TO
CLAPPER AND BRENNAN, ABSOLUTELY
HERE AND TERROR IN THE HEARTS
AND MINDS OF ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE, BECAUSE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL SHOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT THEY WERE
UP TO, THE ANXIETY IS PALPABLE,
TONIGHT THE DEEP STATE IS IN
FULL PANIC MODE.
THEY ARE EVEN THINKING BIGGER
HOLES EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY
OPEN THEIR MOUTHS.
FRANKLY, SAD TO WATCH, BUT
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET RIGHT.
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> I SEE IT AS A VERY SERIOUS
OUTRAGEOUS MOVE ON THE PART OF
MR. TRUMP ONCE AGAIN TRAMPLING
UPON THE STATUTORY AUTHORITIES
OF THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND THE HEAD OF
INDEPENDENT INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
I KNOW THAT MY FORMER COLLEAGUES
IN THE INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES ARE
LOOKING UP ON THIS WITH GREAT
CONCERN AND WORRY.
>> I WONDER WHAT ELSE IS GOING
TO BE CLASSIFIED THAT RISKS
JEOPARDIZING SOURCE OF METHOD.
>> Sean: NO ONE WOULD RISK
SOURCES AND METHODS.
FOR THEM SELF PRESERVATION AT
THIS MOMENT IS NOW THE KEY OF
THE DAY.
ALWAYS CLEARLY IMPORTANT THAN
PRESERVATION OF CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND OUR CONSTITUTION, RULE OF
LAW.
THE SAME GOES FOR THE INTEL
CHAIRMAN, WELL-KNOWN LIAR, THE
COWARDLY ADAM SCHIFF.
CALLING BARR'S INVESTIGATION
UN-AMERICAN.
THE SAME ADAM SCHIFF WHO TWEETED
THIS IN DECEMBER OF 2016,
PRESIDENT OBAMA CAN AND MUST BE
CLASSIFIED AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
ABOUT RUSSIAN HACKING OUR
ELECTIONS, REST ASSURED THAT
TRUMP WON'T.
AND I HAVE OFFERED HIM FOUR
HOURS OF AIRTIME, THREE ON THE
RADIO SHOW, ONE HERE.
WHY WON'T HE COME ON?
WE HAVE EVERY SINGLE LIE THAT HE
HAS TOLD YOU, BLEED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE IS A LIAR, A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST.
IN THE WORST PART IS, WE NOW
KNOW THAT HE IS LYING.
A CONSPIRACY HACK THROUGH AND
THROUGH, AND WE HAVE A LYING
PARTISAN HACK IN CHARGE OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THAT IS SCARY.
BUT REST ASSURED, BARR IS NOT
GOING TO RELEASE SOURCES AND
METHODS WERE HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
INTELLIGENCE, AND LET'S NOT
FORGET THAT THOSE WHO ARE NOW
SAYING OH, WE CAN'T RELEASE
LISTS ARE THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
WERE ASKING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES BARR TO
BREAK THE LAW AND RELEASE THE
MUELLER REPORT WITH GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY INCLUDED.
THAT IS SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE.
WE ARE ABOUT TO SEE IMPORTANT
EVIDENCE SURROUNDING THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION
SCANDAL.
THE PRESIDENT DECLASSIFIED, IT
WILL COME OUT.
WE WILL LEARN THE EXTENT OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUYING EFFORTS INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, FORMER
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATES CARTER
PAGE JUST REVEALED THAT HIS
CONTACTS WITH THE FBI INFORMANT
STEPHAN HELPER WERE EXTENSIVE.
AND CONTINUE FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR.
SPANNING A TIME PERIOD BEFORE
AND AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION.
THAT'S RIGHT, SPYING OCCURRED.
JAMES COMEY SAYS I DID NOT SPY,
BUT HE ASSIGNED THE FIRST FISA
WARRANT, WE WILL FIND HOW AND
WHY HILLARY CLINTON'S FORNEY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT SHE PAID
FOR AND NEVER TOLD THE FISA
COURT JUDGES THAT SHE PAID FOR
IT WAS USED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS ALLIES.
WE ALSO LEARNED ABOUT MEDIA
LEAKS WERE RAMPING BIAS, AND
LOSING INALIENABLE RIGHTS WERE
TRAMPLED ON.
AND WE COULD WELL UNCOVER THE
ROLE OF SOME OF THE CLOSEST
ALLIES, BUT ARGUES PROBABLY
GREAT BRITAIN, PROBABLY
AUSTRALIA, PROBABLY ITALY, BUT
I'M JUST GUESSING, WHAT DO I
KNOW, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS ONE
OF THE MOST RESPECTED PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND HE HAS BEEN
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
HE IS GOING TO LOOK AT A LOT OF
DOCUMENTS, SOME HE MAY FIND
INTERESTING, MAYBE HE WILL FIND
NONE INTERESTING, BUT FOR OVER A
YEAR PEOPLE HAVE ASKED ME TO
DECLASSIFIED, SO WHAT I HAVE
DONE AS I HAVE DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING.
HE CAN LOOK.
AND I HOPE THAT HE LOOKS AT THE
U.K.
AND I HOPE THAT HE LOOKS AT
AUSTRALIA, AND I HOPE THAT HE
LOOKS AT THE UKRAINE, AND I HOPE
THAT HE LOOKS AT EVERYTHING.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A HOAX THAT
WAS PERPETRATED ON OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: PERPETRATED ON THE
COUNTRY, AS PER USUAL, GETTING
TO THE TRUTH WILL NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT A FIGHT.
THIS IS NOW AN IMPORTANT MISSION
FOR ALL OF US.
AS AMERICANS TO PRESERVE,
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES.
LOOK AT THE DOSSIER OFFER,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, REFUSING TO
COOPERATE WITH BARR'S
INVESTIGATION?
WHY DON'T WE EXTRADITE HIM, WHY
DON'T WE TOLD BRITAIN TO SEND
THEM OVER?
GIVEN THREE YEARS AGO,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS READY TO
TALK TO ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY IN
THE GOVERNMENT ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
LIES.
AND ACCORDING TO A BIG NEW
REPORT, SARA CARTER,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER AND
JOURNALIST, AJI BARR RESISTING
FROM THE INTEL AGENCY "THIS IS
NOT JUST ABOUT TRUMP, IT IS
ABOUT A NEARLY A DECADE OF ABUSE
INSIDE THE INTEL COMMITTEE AND
BOROUGH WITH COLLECTION
AUTHORITY."